un fragmento, es decir, debe ser arado probablemente
algún tipo de acero que no conozco allí
armadura extra lo mejor
inquilino de la casa
durante
aire potencial
Esto es para
no les importa un comino yo
apuró la cuenta hasta 10
[música]
todo esta bien pero es un skoda
rizalo vete al mar
es un cohete
[música]
dónde
practica rodis
especialmente único en el sentido de que es único y
ella misma especial no con babosas 10 ciudad
multinacional eso es eso eso es todo
la diversidad es muy fuerte
influyó en la diversidad de la arquitectura
con el tiempo aqui seria para el hilo de pescar
tradiciones que eran absolutamente
único en esta ciudad
[música]
nuestro museo
de mi cuenta practica 100 rocky
llevado a 24 museo vivo museo feroz
desarrollado al acostarse fuertemente
rehén ucrania volúmenes alma grandes planes
estoy en camino
[música]
Todavía estaba tratando ahora seré sucio usa 23
intenso
rimel extraído syany podría incluso respirar
mucho tiempo me quede dormido y luego me fui
cerrado el kilogramo y la realidad en él
vino
realmente fui al museo y al siguiente
día tomamos la mano y la voluntad
lidiar con el desmantelamiento en el medio
colección desmontaje exposición por
bañarse en la documentación lejana es
cubierta de un grupo inferior
éxito soplado por la dirección dispersa brisa
soplar como a la cinta daría
los polacos franceses los búlgaros gritan y
hoy los perros se atragantan con tolerancia
mes para ush luego viene con buena
números
[música]
hay tal momento que esos arquitectos
que eran de origen ucraniano
construido bastante brillante e interesante y
quizás el menos conocido de ellos
Miroshnichenko está realmente aquí
en Zhukovsky en primer lugar nosotros
considerar como el trabajo de Miroshnichenko
precisamente el alerón delantero
en las paredes esto es despues
alguien hizo reparaciones desde la oficina de vivienda, pero esto
Hace cuarenta años había algo
pintaron después de quitar el nabo
solemos hablar de la entrada aquí
la escena es maravillosamente hardware aquí en nuestro
yarda
[música]
naturalmente una parte integral de todos
casa histórica en odessa es la puerta
esta es la entrada
que, de hecho, como la cara del proyecto, entonces antes
lo que un residente toca todos los días
[música]
para el 4 de febrero para casi inmediatamente
estaba ocupado con el trabajo y
dejar de
para que nos sintamos a gusto
trae un gran alivio
trabajar no sólo en la eliminación de pintura en
restauración general
carpintería
del siglo XIX porque bajo los sonidos de las sirenas y bajo
todos estos son los problemas apremiantes con los que
enfrentado
restauración de este viejo
productos nos permite centrarnos en
enfoque de la vida en el arte
[música]
[aplausos]
Todos
3 y adolescentes conchas mientras estábamos comprometidos
lingual
documental otro también lo haremos a expensas de
que llamó al santo y la cuenta de la hierba de vino y
luego vino tal sabe incluso siendo
perspicacia contar acto sucede
en busca de ayuda, que dejen ir la sala y el museo
para intercambiar y encontrar vidvidovacha
tops corre hice rabioso d aquí
hervir el hombro no cuenta para tal
personal personal lo que sea clásico
habilidad
[música]
bueno, por supuesto, más allá de contar eso
los huéspedes de la ciudad también
contemplar esta belleza bajo qué
museo al aire libre de odessa no importa cómo
girar y
de hecho, si entramos en el museo, vemos
hay pinturas en un edificio, entonces todo está aquí
edificios que tienen estos
fotos y me gustaría, por supuesto, que
bastante vida para descubrirlo todo
muestra estas fotos
arte para que la gente pueda
disfrutar y creer en lo que fortalecer
esta fe en lo que
la ciudad es realmente histórica, sí, entonces
hay que la union sovietica solo
conserva todos estos murales que
están bajo capas de pintura
están destruidos y de qué se trata
guardar sujetar
[música]
disco de la planta de residuos
historia de las zapatillas para personas que ya son más
cuenta toque soldados rusos yaki
moyut el derecho a sv se extingue y quita los derechos
Di que no, no quiero ir a Ucrania.
no quiero disparar no quiero vanin
amasar personas son monumentos culturales
Estoy en el baño de novato de la mente y sobre el pensamiento
Robando pipas que empezaste aquí, seremos yo
Confieso aquí tales síndromes aquí estás aquí
tal garmin empezaras en la cama
[música]
spadchyna escalera de brigadas y estudio alli
la historia es que un hombre sabiendo que fuma
otto cronología 1 de marzo sin antecedentes en
puede establecer acciones
vínculo trascendental con la dulce tú
Budova en estos planes de Yakis para mis días de semana
[música]
y ver visualmente lo que se está filmando
la pintura va algún proceso de alguna manera
calma aparece algún tipo de fe en
el hecho de que todo saldrá bien y a pesar del hecho
que algo está siendo destruido en alguna parte
considerado para destruirnos a todos estamos aquí
en la zona
aquí está la historia
tratando de abrir show asi es todo
fue entonces cuando la gente vio
120 150 200 años atrás
[música]
hoy estamos bajo el control de
coleccionar lo mismo no es su colección de nidadas en
ella se nos apareció en el sofá a la vez y
donde estoy cerca de los ojos eres nosotros
lo desglosaremos podemos sermonear
gire allí soy roma buscándote te gustará
can skyresh y ricos gestos de nuestro museo
por 24 tal vez tenga un siglo retirarme y sentarme
él descaradamente no sostuvo podemos duzhe shvidko
de modo que
adiós línea jacques louis david wate
nueva ucrania para un nuevo modelo
nuestros primeros con Crimea, luego daré de acuerdo con el art.
[música]